chi di voi conosce questa donna immagini
che nessuno vero eppure cosa cosa mi
direste se vi dicessi che questa donna e
mode e mail ha cambiato il mondo che il
mondo non sarebbe quello che conosciamo
se non ci fosse stata lei ma chi era
immagini il prima di rispondere
facciamo un piccolo piccolo passo
indietro a quando avevo 8 anni e andiamo
a vedere questa foto
ecco questo sono io e te io sono quello
in basso a sinistra quello sotto
l'allenatore che sto cercando di fare
una cosa strana con le dita così ecco la
mia grande passione il calcio il mio
sogno di una vita diventare un
calciatore ma c'era un piccolissimo
problema prima partitina di allenamento
il mister quello che era proprio sopra
di me mister roberto butta la palla in
mezzo e ci fa giocare per decidere un po
nostri ruoli sai che era bravo chi un po
meno bene mi arriva la palla porta vuota
tiro palo il mister fischia mi chiama
enrico ti devo parlare mi fa e dal campo
mi sposta alla porta che di fare il
portiere che per chi non lo sapesse
spesso insomma il ruolo in cui si
relegano quelli che sono un po scarsi
vabbè io penso dai posso rifarmi come
portiere forse prima partita ufficiale
io sono il portiere 6 a 1 per quegli
altri ho preso sei gol di cui uno è
incredibile autogol mio in rovesciata da
terra una cosa c'è l'acrobazia pazzesca
finisce la partita il mister mi fa
enrico ti devo parlare dalla porta
risposta alla panchina a fare la riserva
della riserva della riserva bene ok e
poi succede una cosa strana un mattino
mentre sono a scuola bus
e c'è questo signore che si definisce un
allenatore sta formando una squadra di
studenti per partecipare a un torneo
studentesco dice bene ragazzi
chi di voi ama giocare a calcio
naturalmente tutti alzano le mani e ci
troviamo 40 ragazzini fuori in cortile
di 10 anni
con questo allenatore mai visto mai
conosciuto che ci dice voi 20 state di
qua noi 20 state di là io li butta la
palla in mezzo e voi giocate non avevamo
neanche le casacche cioè un casino
pazzesco volavano un certo punto mosse
di karate a cielo aperto e non fischiava
mai la palla neanche la vedevi eppure un
certo punto mi arriva la palla non so
nemmeno io come e io scarto due
avversari almeno credo fossero avversari
insomma li scarto 0 palo minister per la
prima volta fischia
ti devo parlare di nuovo invece no mi fa
tu sei bravo tu sarai il capitano della
mia squadra
io sì sì tu sarà il capitano di questa
squadra e poi è successa una cosa
pazzesca andiamo a fare questo torneo e
tutti si fidavano di me mi passavano la
palla io mi fidavo di me io ho segnato
anche diversi gol ma ma così è successo
perché nella mia squadra di periferia no
era una schiappa la riserva della
riserva della riserva e invece con la
squadretta della scuola ero ronaldo ma
cosa ha un nome quello che mi è successo
quello che è successo in quel momento ed
è una cosa che in realtà accade a tutte
le latitudini ed è successo anche a
tutti voi
si chiama effetto pigmalione o anche
effetto rosenthal
ma chi era questo rosenthal rosenthal è
uno psicologo 1963 harvard sta facendo
degli esperimenti sul pregiudizio umano
e usa dei topini da laboratorio per fare
i suoi esperimenti e questi esperimenti
danno dei risultati incoraggianti
pubblica un articolo e e tutti insomma
si diffonde diventa famoso e gli arriva
una letterina da parte di una
giovane preside di una scuola vicino a
san francisco dall'altra parte degli
stati uniti e gli dice senti rosenthal
viene a fare i tuoi esperimenti qui da
me e rosenthal dice perché hai dei
topini particolari tu non so no no vieni
vieni a farla con gli studenti che
topini e lui prende un aereo e va lì e
insieme a questa preside che si chiamava
lenord jakobson mettono a punto uno
scherzo uno scherzo che ha fatto la
storia
funzionava così dunque in questa scuola
si chiamava la hop school come molte
scuole americane le classi erano divise
in modo molto rigido fra classi veloci
classi medie e classi lente per decidere
dove mettere gli studenti
somministravano a inizio anno dei test
di intelligenza bene rosenthal con ely
somministra anche lui questi test di
intelligenza ma poi arriva lo scherzo
non fa vedere i risultati giusti ma li
mescola fa credere agli insegnanti che
un 20 per cento di studenti scelti
totalmente a caso glieli presenta come
dei geni a questo qua bravissimo questa
qua dalle solo un po di tempo vedrai
quante soddisfazioni ti darà rosenthal
dice bene io vado via torno qui a
frenarlo e mi direte se non avevo
ragione torna dopo un anno rosenthal
perché dei professori e quindi avevo
ragione i processori sei bravissimo i
tuoi test funziona alla grande questi
ragazzi erano i migliori della scuola e
aveva scelti a caso non erano test veri
aspetta aspetta so già so già a cosa
stai pensando stai pensando che se i
professori fanno favoritismi sai il
pregiudizio no ma rosenthal anima da
harvard non faceva le cose a caso
somministro anche di nuovo un nuovo test
d'intelligenza per avere una prova
oggettiva ed effettivamente quel 20 per
cento di studenti era migliorato nella
migliorato in tutte le discipline in
particolare nelle attività di lettura
ma cosa ma come perché è successo questo
cioè è bastato dire un insegnante guarda
questo ragazzo è intelligente e
l'insegnante lo ha fatto diventare
intelligente se è bastato quello una
cosa che ha quasi il sapore del miracolo
della magia infatti un altro nome che si
da questo fenomeno è profezia che si
autoavvera
io predico che tu diventi bravo e la mia
profezia ti fa diventare bravo e
rosenthal decise quindi di chiamare
questo particolare fenomeno oltre che
col suo nome effetto pigmalione ma chi
era pigmalione pigmalione viene da una
commedia di george bernard shaw
bellissima divertentissima dunque la
trama è questa c'è ci sono questi due
amici non un colonnello e un professore
che si annoiano e allora fanno una
scommessa e dicono scommettiamo che dice
il professore io riesco a prendere
questa fioraia qua questa burina volgare
e tela trasformo in sei mesi te la
faccio diventare una nobildonna dai modi
aristocratici e il colonnello a bab
esatto avete capito come una poltrona
per due uguale infatti una potrà per due
viene da lì bene sei mesi
effettivamente il professore ci riesce
trasforma live da questa fioraia che era
veramente imbarazzante nel suo essere
volgare la trasforma in una nobildonna e
nessuno si accorge che la differenza e
come sia riuscito la risposta che è poi
la stessa risposta alla domanda no
perché io a calcio scarso e poi ronaldo
perché i bambini di rosenthal migliorano
celada proprio show per bocca di liza
dentro questa commedia quando liza dice
la differenza fra una fioraia è una
signora non è nel modo in cui lei si
comporta ma nel modo in cui viene
trattata se tu tratti un bambino come se
fosse stupido entra stupido se tu tratto
inondino come se fosse medio diventerà
medium man se lo tratti come se avesse
del talento come se fosse intelligente
come se avesse del potenziale quel
potenziale un giorno
verrà fuori c'è un problema però perché
l'effetto pigmalione funziona anche al
contrario è anche un nome il contrario
ci dice effetto golem
ma io preferisco chiamarlo effetto
voldemort
breve riassunto del riassunto del
riassunto di harry potter visto dagli
occhi di voldemort e voldemort izo un
attimo quel bambino mi ci darà
e allora io lo combatto perché così non
mi ucciderà lo combatto ma poi dopo un
sacco di lotte quel bambino mi uccide
che se non l'avessi combattuto non mi
avrebbe fatto niente sono un genio
profezia che si autoavvera
al contrario vedete io posso scegliere
ogni giorno appena entro in classe se
essere pigmalione possa essere voldemort
ogni momento io posso essere l'uno o
l'altro posso trasformare un carbone in
un diamante ma anche un diamante in un
carbone e allora come si fa
come è possibile cercare di essere
sempre pigmalione mai voldemort
io mi sono dato otto regole 8 come le
regole del fight club quindi un attimo
kimi brad pitt izzo la prima regola
dell'effetto pigmalione e non devi
dimenticare mai il pigmalione la seconda
regola dell'effetto pigmalione non
dimenticare mai pigmalione perché queste
due regole perché siamo esseri umani si
si lo so sembra strano anche noi
insegnanti siamo esseri umani ma abbiamo
pregiudizi non è giusto o sbagliato
bello brutto è umano avere pregiudizi la
cosa importante è non dimenticarsi mai
che se sei un insegnante se sei un
educatore se sei un genitore i tuoi
pregiudizi hanno un effetto cambiano la
realtà
terza regola questa non è mia ma è di
maria montessori lei la considerava la
sua regola deontologica un po come
giuramento d'ippocrate degli insegnanti
e diceva che ogni insegnante deve
astenersi dal pensare male di uno
studente
capita a tutti ed è capitato anche a me
di arrivare a pensare ok questo non ce
la fa con questo questo è un caso perso
non ce la farò mai questo quarto ecco
non farlo non farlo perché se è vero che
ti succede di pensarlo non devi mai
dimenticare che se lo pensi potrebbe
essere proprio il tuo pensiero che lo fa
succedere quarta regola tratta ogni
studente come se avesse dentro di sé un
talento straordinario
perché è vero è così il talento è come
il magma scorre sotto la terra forte
potente ma sotto non si vede il talento
ha bisogno come il magma di una fessura
per uscire per come dicono i geologi con
quella bellissima espressione per venire
a giorno ecco fa in modo di cercare di
essere sempre tu quella fessura che un
giorno far esplodere il suo talento come
un vulcano
questa regola scriviti tutti i suoi
pregi proprio scrivi lì è su un foglio
su un diario dove sull'applicazione note
del cellulare basta che li scrivi quando
li vedi ti devi mettere giù uno per uno
ogni volta sesta regola di glieli glieli
devi dire lui lo deve sapere quali sono
i suoi pregi perché la nostra identità
non è qualcosa che ci facciamo da soli e
come una casa che ci costruiamo con i
mattoni che ci danno gli altri i mattoni
degli altri cosa sono
sono le parole sono gli altri che ci
permettono di riconoscerci di sapere chi
siamo ecco fa in modo di dargli sempre
dei buoni mattoni dei mattoni solidi in
modo che quella casa venga su forte e
bella settima regola si scriviti anche i
suoi difetti
iscriviti anche quelli ma non dirglielo
quelli li tieni temi per te non per
sempre
no fino al giorno in cui avrai to capito
come può usare quei difetti perché è una
verità universalmente riconosciuta che
tutti i nostri difetti soprattutto i
peggiori possono diventare se usati bene
i nostri maggiori punti di forza ecco di
glieli suoi difetti solo quando tu avrai
scoperto come potrà usarli ottava e
ultima regola indiana jones
vi ricordate con la scena di indiana
jones no alla fine della de l'ultima
crociata lì che arriva davanti al
fossato c'è la grotta con dentro il
santo graal
ma in mezzo c'è questo fosse lunghissimo
e lui non sa come fare come
attraversarlo il quaderno gli dice che
deve avere fede e lui un certo punto
dice va beh devo fare un balzo della
fede chiude gli occhi appoggia il piede
occhi chiusi e il piede incontra un
ponte ecco è esattamente la stessa cosa
per noi
devi avere fede proprio perché non si
vede proprio perché tu ci devi credere
perché nel momento in cui tu credi in
lui lui inizierà a credere in se stesso
e adesso ne ho vedere chi era questa
immagini il questa persona qua che ha
cambiato il mondo
dobbiamo tornare di nuovo negli anni
sessanta è di nuovo in california vicino
a san francisco sempre c'è sto ragazzino
che è un teppista a sette anni ha già
preso tre sospensioni la terza perché ha
nascosto sotto la cattedra della maestra
una carica esplosiva processori
convocano il preside i genitori sentite
ci dispiace prossimo anno vostro figlio
lo dobbiamo mettere in una classe
speciale per bambini speciali perché
troppe troppe difficoltà i genitori che
sono i suoi genitori adottivi dicono no
no no
nostro figlio noi lo conosciamo bene è
molto dotato dategli ancora un anno per
favore piuttosto magari fate di cambiare
insegnanti no bene il preside spostano
arriva quindi questa nuova maestra per
lui e questa maestra cambia totalmente
atteggiamento lo loda di
lo incoraggia vita degli incarichi di
responsabilità insomma lo prende in
fiducia e lui cambia totalmente fa di
tutto pur di compiacere la pur di
entrare nelle sue grazie e ce la fa e
dopo poco tempo vedete i test di
intelligenza che lo somministrano quando
ormai da otto anni e rimangono tutti
esterrefatti a 8 anni dimostrano
intelligenza di un di un ragazzo di 15
pazzesco quel ragazzino poi crescerà
diventerà adulto andrà all'università e
insieme ad un suo amico fonderà una
compagnia di computer che in pochi anni
diventerà la più importante compagnia di
computer al mondo
va beh abbiamo capito che erano questo
ragazzino teppista sono mera steve jobs
e steve jobs fino agli ultimi giorni
prima di morire ha sempre ricordato la
sua maestra come la persona che gli ha
cambiato la vita come la persona senza
la quale lui non sarebbe diventato
quello che poi è diventato il nome di
questa maestra era immagini e grazie
[Applauso]